today we're going to talk about a food
that needs no introduction we're talking
about ice cream hi my name is Anissa
Ramirez welcome to science explained
last year the United States consumed
over a billion and a half gallons of ice
cream that's equal to about 2,300
Olympic size pools or 11 and a half
million bathtubs amazing that's a lot of
ice cream from a science point of view
ice cream is pretty amazing too
first all three states of matter coexist
we have air bubbles a gas liquid of milk
and also we have ice crystals which are
a solid all living together in a yummy
combination now in order to make ice
cream what you need to do is make a
concoction of milk and sugar and
flavoring and mix them all together and
cool them to very very low temperatures
one way that you can do that is with
liquid nitrogen liquid nitrogen is
really cold it's minus 320 degrees
Fahrenheit or minus 230 degrees Celsius
that's as cold as Neptune so let's see
what happens ooh that's neat all right
so if I mix this and continue to add
liquid nitrogen and keep stirring it
I'll eventually get ice cream now
this ice cream is the best ice cream
you're going to get because the ice
crystals are super small because we've
cooled it with really really cold
temperatures and it's going to make the
ice cream really really creamy if you
don't have liquid nitrogen available you
can also make ice cream at home with
things that you have in your
refrigerator you can make a combination
of super cold liquid how do you do that
well you add salt to ice now when you
add salt this is called freezing point
depression this happens all the time
when cities put salt out on the snow
what they're really doing is they're
lowering the freezing point so that
liquid will be present at those
temperatures so what else can we learn
about ice cream
well when you melt ice cream and
refreeze it it's not the same
it changes permanently that's because
the ice crystals
grow to be bigger and bigger and change
the texture now this may not seem very
serious but scientists are interested in
this because this tells us about other
things like avalanches avalanches occur
because snowpack has different crystal
sizes and eventually it gets to a point
where it's unstable and causes snow to
travel at a hundred miles per hour
that's no joke
so you see ice cream has a lot of
lessons in it not only does it tell us
how to create tasty treats but it also
teaches us how to prevent ourselves from
serious threats
I'm Anissa Ramirez thank you for joining
me at signs explained and I hope that
you'll come back for another edition